we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented
by labyrinth welcome everyone and thank
you for joining
today's keynote presentation titled
pattern
evidence reconstruction it's my pleasure
to introduce you
to our speaker today dr henry lee
acai professor university of new haven
chief emeritus connecticut state police
director and of the research and
training center
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab
button at the top of your screen if you
have any questions that arise
during the presentation we encourage you
to submit
your answers i mean i'm sorry your
questions in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following the presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process
to obtain those credits please join me
now in welcoming
our keynote presenter dr henry
lee i will now turn the presentation
over to him
welcome sir uh
good morning everybody today we're going
to talk about
pattern as evidence
as you probably know the criminal
investigation
at the crime scene foreign scientist
police officer detective will often
go through the central dogma of a
forensic examination
forensic science is a little bit
different
than other scientific fields such as
chemistry
biology molecular biology or in the
medicine
we separate our work in three
stages the first stage called scene
processing
scene processing start recognition we'll
have to recognize the potential evidence
not everything at the crime scene
is physical evidence so recognition is
the first step
once you recognize this potential
evidence
you have to document preserve and
collect
the next stage is laboratory process
those collected physical evidence is
submitted to the laboratory
we through identification comparison
that with instrumental biological
physical
other type of examination comparison
let me individualize that particular
evidence
from there the third stage of uh
is core processing we have to transmit
our report
with the documentation to the court of
the law
either through the prosecution
prosecutor or the defense
the defense attorney into the court
once the evidence introduced the court
will have to testify
and we not only testify our result but
also make interpretation and
reconstruction
physical evidence come from all
different forms
there are so many different ways to
classify
the physical evidence
i generally put into the following
seven categories transit evidence
which means something can change quickly
pattern evidence is what we're going to
address today
then conditional evidence transfer
evidence
associated with evidence uh electronic
and medical evidence
last lecture will already cover on those
but today we're going to talk about
pattern evidence
what we're going to do today
we're going to talk about what is part
of evidence
how is it involved in crime scene
what type of paradigm evidence can be
found at the crimes
and where to fund it
how to find it how
is it collected how it should be
handled and preserved
how is it examined
and what's the evidential volume
of those pattern evidence in an
investigation
and the last we're going to cover
pattern evidence reconstruction
what is evidence pattern evidence
there are so many books paper published
devon different meanings definitions
procedures pattern evidence
generally created from different objects
when they have a physical contact with a
surface
to surface and leave behind some
imprint impression indentation
evidence pattern evidence can be visible
or latent may found a variety
type of object and surface
there are guidelines friendliness and
onset
so the examination
of those physical evidence shall follow
the national guideline
what is crime scene reconstruction
the crime scene reconstruction is the
scientific analysis of crime
the crime scene using pattern evidence
logic physical evidence
the result of testing laboratory testing
to test their hypothesis about what did
happen
how did it happen what did happen
what the sequencing back at the currency
crime scene reconstruction usually we
need the following
laboratory result of physical evidence
scientific analysis and observation of
the crime scene
recognition and interpretation of the
pattern evidence at the scene
the systematic study of any other
related information
utilize the big data
develop a logic hypothesis
then we use scientific results to test
those hypotheses and here
we come with a viable theory that's
called
crime scene reconstruction
here is an example
i was called to the scene at the unknown
time
initially it looks like a traffic
accident
however the crime scene patent
indicates it's inconsistent
with a typical traffic accident
a car vehicle in the middle of the
parkway victim's body
found next to the vehicle
with his pants done
of course that's against the common
sense
how many drivers drive the car with
pants done
in addition we noticed
victim was shot twice behind the
are two bullet holes found a windshield
we saw those patterns
indicate to us this vehicle
probably have three occupants
the victim more likely is sitting
uh front driver's seat
the shooter is random behind
in the backseat but it's on the
trajectory
so just look at the pattern
we already developed a hypothesis
it's more likely it's a homicide it's
not a
traffic accident to suspect
more likely in the woods or left to see
already
with that
we start looking at the pattern evidence
usually where can we farm those
impression imagine soft material
or a surface such as soil
sand snow and the sea
indentation or damage made by force
onto a surface imprint
made by dirt thus soil
deposit on the flight flat
and the hard surface impression
made by object
with the dust or wet waxed
greasy surface imprint made by transfer
of blood
body fluid ink or
grease like a material a ink like
material
for example an outdoor crime scene
a investigator some step on a
soil surface some step on a concrete
surface
other on the grass each of them
left some imprint impression
or indentation
another example
the breaking
[Music]
rubbery case we look at the glass
the fragment and fracture mark
that tell us
the direction of the force
the type of material
used to break the window
this is a vehicle
you're bobbing across left behind the
scene
so on the surface of the vehicle as you
can see
different type of mark the roof
all those are pattern evidence
we use a laser light source
try to examine those patterns
pattern evidence can also form
on the other piece of physical
investments
for example this is a plastic bag
but on the back we
[Music]
can see fingerprint we can see folding
mark
we say writing all carnival
those are formal paragraphs
this is a homicide c of course we can
see blood pattern
hand prints and
of course the damage pattern on the wall
so pattern evidence actually consists
so many different categories such as
fingerprint
hampering gloves sock spring
i just want to give you some example
give a year nose print by mark
handwriting wounds and injury blood
pattern fabric pattern
body condition ammo pattern medusa
prender
this means matter of operation
and void spring fire burn pattern
tire track marks to mark cutting mark
machine mark
weapon bullet casing gsr pattern
trajectory pattern
even instrumental data for example
gc chart math back
chart those are pattern two stamp
type all those are patterns
those patterns some were familiar with
such as fingerprint striation mark on
the bullet
tire mark at the same or
a blur stem pattern
some of the pattern which we use for
identification
for example a fingerprint we want to
compare
the fingerprint known records to
identify
the individual laptop interpret the
bullish strategy mark
we want to associate to certain type of
weapon
higher mark samsung blood pattern
besides
identify the source of the blur
in addition we can see this
we are still not complete drawing
it's semi-coagulated that gives us
indication how long those will have been
shaped those are pattern for
reconstruction
for example this lock was on top of the
blur
which means after blood deposit
this log was broken so
with that in mind
pattern identification
for example handwritings
palm prints fingerprints
mark we can identify the type of a
cutting instrument
with a mass back or
even dna that's also a pattern
recognition
we recognize the pattern those pattern
is for
individualization to
identify certain drugs certain body
fluid
or a individual
dna but there are some marks
patterns will use for interpretation
we know those are sharp instruments
left as a major mark
we can make interpretation the direction
of those mark was making and
whether or not made by
another individual or by
the victim hemo herself
even a college
uh test exam
we can look at a exam paper
to determine the eurasia
and look at
the marking whether or not
made by the same pencil
or by same individual
those marking and uh erasure
of course those are just interpretation
you cannot really trace to the source of
origin
in between this is pattern
reconstruction
for example a fire when i get there
i notice there are five origin
dark red those
indicates probably 700
to 900 fahrenheit cherry red
the temperature indicates about
1100 to 1300 fahrenheit
yellowish cherry red is hotter above 14
to 1500
uh yellow uh
which even higher now bright
yellow that's probably got to 21
hundred fahrenheit so from the pattern
we can recognize different origin
different temperature
that's a suspicious fire
through the burn pattern we can also
make
interpretation though the direction
of the fire melting objects
what type of temperature can reach
at the fire scene those objects melting
left behind the shoe print can tell us
how many people and what the direction
[Music]
here another example of a homicide scene
the blur pattern the deposit
of the towel on
the blood floating pattern and nobler
at the west west basket
blood smear on the countertop each of
those
give us some information about this
currency
so where and how to fund a patent
evidence
obviously at the crime scene
crime scene
can be as huge as
the whole airport or a whole house
can be as small as a
piece of hair or fingernail you might
pollen particles
so how and where
we can find evidence
before we talk about how to fund
evidence
we want to know something called linkage
theory
in late 18th century
we all know something called the cars
transfer theory locale
is a well-known forensic scientist
he come up that theory when two objects
in contact
they have a mutual transfer between the
border
the linkage theory is slightly different
if built on the car's theory of transfer
we have to consider the victim the
evidence
and the crime scene and suspect the
four-way
linkage transfer
victim can leave the evidence at the
scene
and also suspect contact the victim
can have a mutual exchange of the
material
also we have to consider so-called
secondary transfer
given no direct contact may have
transferred too
so once we know this linkage theory
so where to find it not become
elementary of course at the crime scene
the point of entry point of exits
passed to target area to target
to target area we can bomb pattern
evidence on physical evidence
such as object closing tools
locks door window safe we can find the
body later i will give you some example
on somebody victim's suspect's hair
for example gun charge residual pattern
on the suspect's hand can tell us the
individual may discharge
or handle or touch a fire
the distribution of the gunshot residual
victim's body we can determine
estimate the distance between a barrel
to the target area
so at the crime scene we look for
pattern evidence point of entry
that's the area usually
leave some evidence
uh how we found it generally
if the pattern is visible
that's much easier but many times
the pattern evidence is not so visible
we have to use
lighting dark the rome
new side lighting helping us
to look for pattern evidence
sometimes we have to use chemical
filming technique for example a vehicle
we know more likely a person
enter the vehicle may
touch the front area
so we try to search those area
for pattern evidence
once you
recognize i did
identify those pattern evidence at the
scene
we have to protect those evidence
generally cover
the area avoid contamination
or step on it otherwise the case is
going to have
difficulty for example
the famous oj simpson case
dna found at the scene
scientifically now that in my mind
i re view those dna results
from los angeles police department
department of justice and uh
other laboratory dna laboratory testing
so when i testify i say the dna
impact is contributed
and by o.j
simpson except
the evidence was collected item 48
1552 uh
june 13
june 12 they collect june 13
dry overnight june 14 they start
sampling
the serological tests then dna
extraction
dna testing however when we examine
the evidence i notice
their pattern evidence
so-called blood
imprint on the packet
which means something have to transfer
those pattern even today we still don't
know
how those patterns get done there
another example two drop a liquid
was found on a walkway
dna is o.j simpsons
however one drop is complete dry
why is what if two drops would deposit
at the same time same day same
temperature
semaparma from the same person same
receiving that
surface not to drop should be the same
but crab pattern show us different
of course injury pattern shoe print
pattern
the button here broken
this pattern those pattern indicates
a struggle and those are some
differential so pattern evidence
play an important role in the outcome
of the case how to bond it
basically we follow a systematic and
logic
examination of the scene
we darken the area use as strong
side lighting light sources search the
area
with oblique lighting will enhance
the suspect pattern
with variety of scientific method
later we're going to cover that
so at the scene the first thing we have
to recognize
this is a triple homicide scene
we found casing the casing
ejection pattern
give me indication
the shooter's location
the casing also tell us
itself the fire front semi-automatic
weapon
the shoe print the stuff left behind
each of those patterns yield information
so at the scene investigator
and forensic scientist
we have to recognize
understand the importance of others
especially the location
of those evidence the pattern the
condition
we have to document thoroughly
so crime scene investigation not just
picked up the evidence
putting the evidence back
we have to photograph document those
pattern evidence
we generally start with our overall view
then we should photograph
the evidence with scale then take
close-up
photograph we also have to take
measurement
sketch and documentation
[Music]
uh we should follow
the guideline
documentation generally
with an overall view then move to a
closer
specific area then we photograph we
scale
once we finish the initial documentation
then we have to look at the close-up
and document
those imprint evidence
we say implant
uh use different photographic technique
can be direct lighting reflect lighting
bounce light
side lighting uh
this can be covered in a different
lecture
so crime scene photograph as i
indicate before start with
overall view let me intervene media
then close up and photo we scale
them evidence model always
have to do the sky sketch and notes
and video taping
enhancement of the pattern can be
photographic method
use oblique lighting uv light
alternative light source let me use
powder dusting or chemical reagent
or a combination
[Music]
with a newer procedure we can also do
mh enhancement that's an example
of side lighting uv lighting
now have so many different light sources
we can use at the crime scene
can helping us discover those patterns
and document those patterns
a hit and run case vehicle when we
examine
the vehicle we notice some damage
on the hello area but
very important is this area
we found a fabric
pattern that's victims
pants so although
we cannot say definitively from our
pants
but that gave us the similar wave
pattern
similar measurement that could have
resolved
from the victim's pants
this case happened in
uh new york um
nassau county a homicide detective
come to our institute took a course
uh of a pattern reconstruction
when he backed to his department
he was called to the scene attempt rape
case
that's a female college suspect
apparently
entered a uh shower room
through the window
that's the shower store a victim
fought the suspect and chased the
suspect
away from the sea uh
detective wing use
the alternative light source
was able to
discover this huge brightness pattern
from that he was able to link one of the
workers
work in a college and solve the case
we use the initial photograph
visible light very difficult
to see the pattern with the side
lighting
uv enhancement then you can
discover that
there's so many different enhancement
reagents
review of the literature
there are more than 20 commonly used
chemical reagent we can use ethyzen
to enhance
generally we fall into the following in
those region falling into the following
seven category
powder dusting
chemical reagent can react with skin
uh him as a monitor of the hemoglobin
which in the human blood or animal blood
any blood source you can use that
or protein enhancement reagent
body fluid enhancement reagent vegetated
material
and chemical elemental enhancement
reagent
here example
use powder dusting we developed this
pattern evidence
bloody enhancement regime
such are orthotolone phenoxylene
titrometer benzene local molecular green
luminol fluorescein
those are some commonly used
versatility because that's potential
carcinogenic
should not use
which we can enhance when you select the
reagent
basically you want the best contrast
look at the substrata the receiving
surface
uh try to find a maximum contrast
so you can document those
this case
there's a homicide case happening in
ohio
and a suspect left a
partial shooting on a sheet
which not really visible however
after we use chemical enhancement
we can see the sneaker the
chevron pattern also
you can use fluorescence chemical to
enhance another major category
is use protein enhancement reagent
from colors reagent react with some
binocial protein
become a color compound commonly used
reagent hygiene amino black
crystal violet dfo chromatic blue
and hundreds and a lot
for example this is the case i call to
the scene
and we was able to develop a pattern
on the victim's body subsequently
through the body
we was able to reconstruct the scene
and solve the case now after you develop
you recognize what you're going to do
with those part inhabitants
of course first to photograph document
do all the measurements at the scene
the maxine try to lift or cast
or dust collect
if the area you can move the piece
evidence
for verbal is moved up complete piece
sent to the laboratory to exam such as
a broken glass a window
or closing floorboard
you have a certain surface
you cannot physically move then you
maybe cut the piece and
to submit to the laboratory so basically
that's the four different way photograph
documentation collect
the island remove the object
cut the surface moisture imprint
so it depends on the situation
then we make a decision what to do
of course there are certain special
lifting techniques such as used genital
lifter
use electronic uh electrostatic
lifter or gel mold casting
different material
now once you lift the evidence
or cut the evidence or submit the
evidence
how you preserve a handle of course
you have to handle with care you don't
want to
destroy the pattern
you don't want to remove or clean the
modifier
or change the pattern
you have to place the suspect
either create a pattern in a separate
uh box instead of mixed together
also you should package
separately carefully and
uh nothing more important
is document thoroughly before
you do any lifting or cutting
so documentation photographing
is very important
now we covered recognition of pattern
identification
document enhancement collection once the
patterns
send overlap generally
laboratory examiner will look at the
pattern
is this a two dimensional
three-dimensional
is that visible latent what's the direct
class characteristics what's the
individual
characteristic you believe
in a flat surface
generally we say that's a two
dimensional
the star was not visible after we
enhanced become a visible piece evidence
ying addition we also
notice there are sequence two type of a
pattern
deposit on top of other
at the scene you can also follow
three-dimensional evidence
uh you should photograph document and
make a casting
don't put your your tool directly into
the imprint
impression area to try to fit that
not going to cause the contamination
so pattern evidence
doesn't matter imprint on impression
it can be deposited by human such as
fingerprint footprint lip brain neoprene
handwriting can be an animal
or vehicle closing
i shall have a g here and uh
objects such as tool mark
mode typewriting pattern
even our human body we often found
pattern evidence i'm sure
you probably have the idea what kind of
pattern
um i'm sure most of you think
that's sick ripper actually
you look at the size and uh
pattern not actually a cigarette
anybody have any idea what kind of
pattern
later you can ask your mate if you don't
know
the next one
the next one of course that's a bi mark
by mark before you do anything
you should photograph and a document
and collect saliva
and dna evidence
the imprint reconstruction often
you can find out the vehicle for example
this vehicle we can find static
transfer evidence it shows the seat
have some kind of a material was put
there
left this pattern
here is another pattern
that can give us some idea
what's there some are difficult
to identify other are pretty easy
for example this one everybody can tell
me
that's a hammer um
many times hit the wrong case for
example
this case
happened in taiwan uh
this is a suspected around
vehicle on a vehicle
there are some patterns here of course
very difficult to read it but
after enhancement
we can easily tell not just three
that's a five that says seven
o-v-t and uh
that's rana vickens license plate
they're also sometime at the scene with
called dynamic contact pattern which
indicates certain force what's involved
for example this tool mark shows us
the direction of the force
for example this blue pattern and medium
velocity
blood cast pattern can give us
information
what type of a weapon what type of
direction
the shubert the movement the contact
all those are examples of dynamic
force so what is the evidence
value for pattern evidence investigation
obviously you can link an object or
vehicle
to the pattern you can link a person
to the pattern evidence to the scene you
can confirm
or refute a statement you can link
a person a vehicle or weapon
or any object to a case you can help to
reconstruct the crime scene
you can develop the investigatively
for example the blue pattern for the
suspects closing
us this individual was above
its bloodshed in case
his statement to police say he did not
know
anything so obviously the pattern
tell us otherwise
the blood pattern shows us
this is a bare footprint
indicates the individual walk on the
concrete
surface did not wear shoes
this is an indentation uh
show us a
work boots
the brand name of the work boots
anybody have any idea what's the brand
name of the
work boots of course
this is one of my
best case here
above a homicide case this is the
vehicle
of course everybody can see a k
and a key ring which indicative
some thing happened given the
distribution
of these two objects
indicate to us is separate from a
keyring
that's more likely it's
a door key
however when we examine the car seat
that's the key that's the keyring but
i'm sure some of you see here have a
patent
that's the pattern which indicative
the key was initially was here somebody
sit
on the seat and uh the key
adhere to the band's deposit to here
and this is the original location
so pattern evidence can really helping
us
to reconstruct for example
this is a another
connecticut tragedy
a church hit the police officer and took
off
at the highway i-84
the investigators stopped by the vehicle
i was called to the scene
this is the one of the vehicle stop the
truck
under 160 we see a pattern
usually hit the run case will look for
blood hair
tissue fabric but this area cannot buy
enabler
hair tissue and fabric
under side lighting which sees its
pattern
but not visible
use chemical filming we saw lighting
we developed a trooper's shoulder patch
that's the victim's shirt
so we a single piece of pattern evidence
we was able to link the suspected
vehicle
to the victim determine
the sequencing band and reconstruct the
case
so general principle in physical pattern
comparison
after we recognize identify
so we can do a direct physical match
or we can include it or
similar or consistent with
or we can exclude or we can reach a
cannot reach a conclusion
insufficient detail or
we call inconclusive or we can exclude
some
pattern or dissimilar
so again this interpretation and the
report
you should follow the guideline and
should meet the core test
this is the suspect's shoes
and uh that's the piece of evidence the
sneaker bring
on a piece type the paper
obviously we say we exclude
that it's not the suspect sneaker
not this pattern
that's just easy
identification we can say that similar
pattern
however is this run our shoes
unless we have significant
individual characteristics and
very difficult to call
so matching is a term
very difficult to use is this a match
uh
of course the striation the inclusion
the mark
it shows that code prana same
origin except now
cores sometimes require statistical
information error rate
many type of pattern evidence we cannot
produce
for example that trooper's shoulder
patch found on the truck
in my whole career we only have one case
i cannot really say statistically
how likely that were produced
reconstruction
is the ultimate goal for pattern
evidence
so at the crime scene if we can
reconstruct
that can give the investigator a lot of
investigative
lead and volume what type of
reconstruction
we can do without pattern evidence we
can look at a
location of the pattern
we can look at the condition of the
evidence
among evidence distribution of the
the sequence whether or not those con
are contaminated or altered
we can identify we can interpret it
for example we can determine how many
tire trucks
uh obviously
we can see two this is on top of this
and uh so you know two different
vehicle left them there are also some
other patterns
so at the scene those patterns
we can study uh provide investigator
some valuable clue for example
the vehicle may deter the direction
and of course if the pattern
have sufficient individual
and class characteristic then you can
link the object
many times the pattern evidence
can help us to eliminate
certain thing or to include certain
individuals
this is a case happening in hawaii
and for a
college student on spring break
somehow the vehicle as you can see
left the mark lost the control
down the clip
because the fire on
four body was called bingoed
victim was identified
zero dental chart
and liege that's the easy part
however later become a major
litigation who is the driver
ah this is one of the victim's shoes
underneath of the shoes as you can see
the pattern
uh that's the brake mark
so
we know this individual have a contact
with this brick left this
mark often at the scene
we also can tell how many people for
example
this scene we see two type of shoe print
so tell us at least
two individual where your mouth
also the pattern can give us
indication what the size
of this shoes what's the possible height
what's the possible bread name of the
shoes
this case victim's body was up on the
kitchen floor
of course the blue smear pattern
indicates us the crazy
or shelter which suggests
the suspect tried to cling up the scene
the blur pattern evidence predominated
on the top of the her garment
and uh which indicative she was on the
ground
and stabbing a curve ah
there are also some uh blue smear blue
imprint we was able to
enhance at the sea
not give us the partial
shubric
that's a close-up for the shoe print
and of course through the data
analysis we was able to identify
the type of use as subsequently the
investigator
was able to link the suspect
not only from the type of evidence
also the choice evidence uh
the blur stem dna
unsuspect shoes and the pattern avenues
of course that's the area
enhanced that's the ink print
that's the suspects used so basically
use padding evidence link the case
and use dna and
link the suspect we can do your bank
reconstruction for example this is
another crime scene
we have a tremendous assembler uh
at the sea victims body of course
the door opened and nobler inside the
drawer
can tell us quite a bit information
on downstairs kitchen floor we found
some pattern
after enhanced we know suspect
wear a work boots
and walk around the scene or
subsequently the case was solved
case happened in florida and
at the scene we see some footprint
run pattern we can determine
the person's trying also the person
more likely male female walking or
running
uh those are the pattern interpretation
but in between have a blood
which indicative uh
have some blood source make up those
vertical deposits uh some pattern
at the sea broken pieces of material
and uh also large of the
amount of bloods that there's no center
so-called closed spray
those material
give us information more likely
somebody tough out the blood and
we was able to reconstruct
and uh of course
uh they gave me a nickname call me king
of the crime scene
now time is up the last
test that's a pattern this case
the victim was a college student
reported police she was
sexually assaulted by
her former boyfriend not only
that she'll serve her or also carve a
heart
in the pond over her head the boyfriend
was arrested
and the boyfriend said no i did not do
that
i did not set shows on her i did not
comfort
her she is crazy about me
she want me to marry her i refuse she
did
herself
this pattern helping us
to look at a false person's
statement which one
is more likely true
okay so with that
i turned uh uh
put into susie
we finished today's lecture
let's start with our first great
question coming in we have some
wonderful questions coming in from our
audience members
dr lee for how long is evidence
preserved how long evidence preserved
that's two different
answer one is at the legal state
each court state a federal case
for example homicide evidence should
preserve forever
many cases early days
for example uh sexual assault only five
years
statue of limitation now they extended
longer than you have to preserve longer
scientifically
in the laboratory when the police submit
to the laboratory
if under laboratory custody laboratory
have to preserve
uh in that period time and tier released
to the submitting agencies
thank you for that and how do you
establish the identity
of the person in a sexual offense
with help of the asthma period
permia semen
okay
in other words the question is if
somebody doesn't have spur
all right there ejaculation has no sperm
however they still have cells body cells
in their summer or fluid so you still
can find
dna in addition you can find protein
markers
you can always do protein markers
plus recover some
cells to do pcr to
enhance str and do dna analysis
thank you very much when new shoes
are made is a pattern of the bottom
supplied
to the database somewhere voluntarily
i wondered about this as well no
question
good question yeah on uh early days
you know i already retire five times so
i don't collect early days my career
we collect your prints and uh
we write into the manufacturer ask for
uh you give us a uh
example we goes to shoe store
uh to look at the pattern uh
susie to tell you uh early days i don't
remember
my wife's birthday
pattern after seeing i can look at the
father and say aha that's
puma sneaker and uh of course today
have they big database a lot of
commercial uh company
they have this database available
a lot of laboratory and different
countries
all have database so hopefully someday
i don't know maybe they already exist
have a
world big database
so everybody can use that
that would be great huh dr lee what was
the pattern
on slide 85
a second i have to look at a sly 85
85 i believe it was the one that you
said
ask me leader had the two marks of those
small marks that we
misinterpreted as cigarette burns oh
he said ask me later uh yes before
this is eddie okay
uh that's a good question what kind of
mark
uh
and it looks like we may have lost dr
lee for a second
i'm sure that he will be right back
we apologize for that
sometimes we have these little moments
of errors in technology
i'm sure this happens all over the world
and each of you have experienced this in
the past
so we apologize
okay this is a
sucking mark it's not the t-smart
it's a mouse contact the surface
interesting yeah very interesting
and thank you for that and again
audience members thank you for your
great questions coming in
secretary what is the most common
manipulation of evidence that forensics
would encounter
can you ask again what's the most common
what is the most common manipulation of
evidence
that forensics would encounter you mean
somebody else manipulate the evidence or
i believe that's yes i believe that's
what they're asking
okay most of the time people try to edit
some more
or try to remove
for example cleaning washing
uh destroy the evidence many times they
threw in some curveball for example
we do have a case somebody where
somebody else shoes
left some uh humping at the sea
or uh of course
uh many times they put the different
people's
clothing and trace evidence sentencing
thank you for that and dr lee how do you
process
latent fingerprints on concrete
surface that's the first part of the
question and which
method is most useful for developing
latent
um fingerprint finger marks on
such surfaces what surfaces
second portion on the concrete surfaces
okay concrete surfaces depends on the
country
uh if a rough surface you cannot
find a readable fingerprint usable
fingerprint
maybe we can use chemical develop
the size of the hand or size of the
finger
make some interpretation
you have a smooth surface
generally we can use fingerprint powder
or use cyanide color filming to develop
the pattern
thank you for that and how many
evidences
are presented in court before a crime
is proven like a homicide
for example okay uh
excellent all those questions are
excellent
okay great um those are great questions
this is
also a question should not ask a foreign
scientist
because people think the movie
and uh television show
sync the forensic scientists we star
brandon crime scene we work in the lab
what goes to car we're dictating the
outcome
how many pieces present but forensic
scientists actually
in a legal setting were not like the
movies
most the forensic scientist doesn't go
to the sea
i'm the few exceptions the crimes he
usually handled by detective
or major crime squad or crime scene
technicians
um what goes to core
not say we want to say what do we want
to say what to present
usually
the lawyers the district attorney
decide what to present what the sequence
to present
what question they ask you
if you are a defense expert you call
to the core uh they just present one or
two pieces
in favor of the defendant they only ask
a few questions nobody want the whole
picture whole story
ah the forensic scientist which is like
a
piece of a music instrument
in the corner depends the musician
and the conductor the site the conductor
basically is the judge so
uh a lot of uh
media coverage criticized the forensic
scientists
not scientifically enough we don't know
what you're doing
but if you look at that carefully
it's not up to the foreign sick
scientist
just like a way don't live like a
uh those movie
uh csi we don't drive pampers
we don't eat in a fancy restaurant
we work around the clock lucky we'll
have a hamburger
good question great questions and we
have quite a few questions and i want to
remind our audience that any questions
we can't answer today
we will be answering via email dr lee
are you up for a couple more
i think that we're already over time
okay
how about one more question okay one
last question okay
i'll ask you this one i know you won't
be able to have time to
talk about it but what was the
hardest case you've had to solve
that's basically case without
information in other words we're not
called to the ce
nor the physical evidence will collect
you are
basically one person statement versus
another statement
you don't have any other direct
physical evidence those are difficult to
solve
i can give you a lot of example but some
other time
when we maybe feature to have a
uh siri unsolvable homicide or something
okay i
want to again thank you susan
thank you taylor lane and uh
that brought the most importantly thank
you all
all those uh audience thank you for
uh listen to my talk
and uh i wish you all
stay safe healthy and
when you go out make sure
put the mask on okay
now i have to leave so i put my mask on
now
thank you again hi dr
dr lee thank you again and thank you for
the audience for
your wonderful questions today as a
final reminder
any questions that were not submitted
will be provided
via email this presentation will be
available on demand viewing until
november
2020 so please share it with your
colleagues who may have missed
today's topic thank you again for your
participation until next time
be safe and stay healthy bye